this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists today we're going to
talk about healing your relationship
with stuff
your relationship with the truth your
relationship with yourself
your relationship with your values and
your money and your creativity and of
course your relationships
with people why because today is the day
ryan
finally love people use things
yeah it's on bookshelves and library
shelves
is this our first hardcover uh well in
america it is we've got a lot of
hardcovers overseas
true but yeah all of our other books
have been soft covers so it's available
right now i'm not going to be labor the
point
hardcover ebook audiobook we'll even
read it to
you i was listening to the the version
of the audiobook i'm going to do a
little bit of reading today
but it's not going to do it justice
because we spent two weeks in the studio
doing the audiobook that was fun man you
know i know this
isn't going to sound very minimalist but
the best way that i take in information
from a book
is i literally like especially if we
have a guest coming on i got to read
their book
like quickly i will get the audio book
and the book book
and i will listen to the audiobook as
i'm reading it yes and then i can like
highlight stuff as i'm going along
anyway
um i'm not encouraging you to do both
i'm just talking about what i do
well you can find at your local library
your local indie bookshop
at target barnes noble amazon all those
other places we'll put links in the show
notes but
since today is a special day we thought
we'd have a very special
guest here in the studio our returning
champion
ninth time guest
[Music]
[Laughter]
everybody welcome tk cole this is ninth
time on the podcast
we're gonna talk about a bunch of stuff
here on this minimal episode healing
your relationship with stuff
creativity we're going to talk a little
bit about distractions as well on the
maximal episode this week
tk i want to dive deep with you we're
going to talk about healing
our relationship with lies many of the
lies the untruths we tell ourselves and
we tell other people
also our relationship with people our
relationship with money
all the tension that it creates also we
have 13
overrated virtues i want to run by you
maybe we can disagree about some things
a little bit tk
i want to start this episode before we
get into the questions i got two
things for you maybe three things ryan i
was stepping onto the elevator in my
building this week
and i got on i was riding the elevator
down to the lobby
and this woman stops uh like on the
fifth floor
and she stops the elevator she gets on
she has this cart full of stuff and she
says can i get on the elevator i said
sure
huge cart full of stuff and then she
looks up at me and she goes oh my god
you're the reason i have all this stuff
i said well wait a minute she goes no i
didn't mean it like that you're the
reason i'm getting rid of all of this
stuff i've been in this building for 35
years and i feel like
i've had all this stuff it's like i have
a life sentence
of stuff in my house 35 years
and now she's finally tackling she saw
our last documentary less is now
on netflix and she had been in the
building since you know the 80s
and now she was finally letting go wow
she found the courage
to let go that's incredible that's what
we're trying to do with this book i want
to start with an excerpt so we can just
sort of talk about
this book intelligently this is from
page 36
this is during the introduction the
introduction chapter is called in an
introduction to living with less this
book's title was inspired by two
unlikely muses
it was the venerable fulton j sheen
circa 1925 who first said
you must remember to love people and use
things rather than to
love things and use people i encountered
this epigram almost daily as a child
every time i walked past my catholic
mother's bedroom and
saw it artfully framed and mounted on
the wall above her bed
nearly a century later pop rap superstar
drake echoed sheen's line when he sang
love well no i don't know what the line
is actually wish you would learn to love
people
and use things and not the other way
around the minimalists reworked the
sentiment to create the catchphrase that
has come to
define our message love people and use
things
because the opposite never works which
ends every episode of our podcast
when ryan and i close our live events
with this line the crowd often
echoes the phrase in unison a few brave
souls have even tattooed the phrase
on their bodies as a permanent daily
reminder i've got a picture in the book
here
of someone this is our salt lake city
event a couple years ago
jordan took a photo of it here and his
photo is in the book
it's pretty cool yeah love people comma
use things right there on her body
minimalism itself is not a new idea the
concept dates back to the stoics to
every major religion to
and more recently to emerson and thoreau
and tyler durden
what's new is the problem never before
have people been more seduced by
materialism and never before have people
been so
willing to forsake loved ones to acquire
heaps
of meaningless stuff with this book we
will shine a new light on minimalism's
time-tested wisdom one lesson at a time
the book's aim isn't to remove you from
the modern world
but rather to show you how to better
live
within it how do we learn to live
confidently without the material things
we've convinced ourselves we need
how do we live a more intentional and
rewarding life
how do we learn to reset our priorities
how do we transform the way we look at
ourselves
how do we get what we want out of life
ryan and i explore these questions
by examining the seven essential
relationships that make us who we are
stuff truth self values money
creativity and people these
relationships crisscross our lives in
unexpected ways
providing destructive patterns that
frequently repeat themselves
too often left unexamined because we
have buried them beneath
materialistic clutter this book offers
the tools
to help in the fight against consumerism
clearing the slate
to make room for a more meaningful life
now here's the point i wanted to get to
here
ryan and i believe that by highlighting
our flaws
and working through our issues publicly
we can help people
deal with our own issues and the shame
that surrounds the decisions of the past
it just so happens that this book is the
best medium for us to
pour our guts onto the page throughout
these pages
we'll use we'll also use expert insights
and case studies to peel back the facade
covering the hidden truths of everyday
people who
who have been hiding their shame like we
once did
under a mountain of useless objects
so there are some stories in this book
ryan drug abuse
arrests yeah theft um infidelity
infidelity ending up in an insane asylum
for a week
a lot of things that we have never
talked about publicly we're not going to
talk about on this episode we may dive
into on a future maximal episode a
little bit but
we wanted to get it out there because
these are sort of everyday things now tk
we all deal with certain struggles in
our life
and we're afraid to admit it because of
the shame because we see
the perfect lives of everyone else now
no one's going to mistake this as
a a memoir of a couple of perfect guys
who have done everything right
i mean we've done everything wrong and
now we've cataloged it we have like
we have proof here thank god for the
statue of limitations because some of
the stuff in here
it's like oh wow i can't believe they
did that i can't believe
that was our life at one point yeah well
i think that's where people learn the
most i mean
we have this weird thing in western
culture i think specifically
of we put our leaders our role models
uh you know celebrities we put them on
this pedestal as if like they should be
perfect or as close to perfect as
possible but what a crappy expectation
because really most of us most of the
world we go through a lot of these
things we go through a lot of tough
situations bad decisions
so you know for for josh and i to put
these stories out there
personally i would rather see a story of
redemption
than a story of perfection and uh
that's what josh and i did with this we
kind of laid it out all out on the table
and um yeah i really hope people
can they probably didn't screw up as bad
as josh and i did
or maybe they didn't but you know
hopefully it's going to do one of two
things it's going to
help people look at uh uh these screw
ups to be like oh yeah
i've done those things too oh and that's
you know here's a path
that i can take to kind of redeem myself
or maybe they'll look at it and they'll
say
man i did not i haven't done any
anything nearly this bad
i can definitely redeem myself oh yeah
so fascinating yeah
so uh yeah it's it was it was it was
hard to tell some of these stories but
i'm glad we did and like i said i think
that that's where people learn the most
they learn
from stories of redemption uh not these
stories of people being perfect
yeah yeah what about utg you ever
screwed up
no not really
you know i was going to say that uh i've
been holding on to this way too long
i was going to say yeah struggle's
definitely real like when you threw that
drake line to ryan and you
completely botched the highlight clip i
was just like oh man
i know i couldn't i don't know i don't
know that line verbatim i know i was
like i was going to try it but i'm like
i'm going to screw this up so bad and
then drake's going to sue us be like you
killed my line when the camera's off
josh's going to be like don't f up the
drake
we practiced this 20 times yeah right
well you know it's funny man because
once upon a time
celebrities were deliberately marketed
as that
i i think this generation's so different
because before you could have this huge
gap between the private life
of a celebrity and you know the public
image and so
you could just present yourself how you
want it to be seen and no one knew
anything about you but now we're in the
age where
you know basketball stars movie stars
they can't hide they're
on social media we're taking pictures of
them when they're having lunch
and so there's a unique dilemma today
where you have to decide what you're
gonna do with
this high level of visibility are you
gonna lean into it and say okay
i'm not gonna wait for tmz to you know
expose me as someone that gets angry
sometime
uh sometimes i'm just gonna tell you i
get angry sometimes i lose my cool
sometimes
and like i think you guys are are taking
the lead with putting yourselves out
there and saying
there's nothing wrong with having your
imperfections exposed
the important thing is that you take the
lead in that process and you're the one
that does it so that you can
de-scandalize it so to speak we need to
de-scandalize imperfection
yeah absolutely you know it's crazy like
my
my 16 year old self i don't know like
there's a couple things i screwed up and
then
you know josh talks about uh spoiler
alert josh talks about the uh the insane
asylum which i guess you could call it
an insane asylum
but you know i had i had overdosed when
i was like 19 years old
so being like in my teens i thought i
would never
maybe i was a little older than that but
it doesn't matter being being young i
never thought i could recover
from something like that like it felt
like a life-ending
um life would never be the same and and
maybe to an extent it wasn't yeah
but yeah i never thought i'd be able to
recover from that and
the fact that you know here i am 40
years old
you know that kid who overdosed like
that is
i don't even know that person you know
it feels like a different life
so uh yeah it's it it's i think
especially for young people
they have these moments they get
embarrassed you know they
they do something and they feel like oh
my life is over
and like really no it's not over like
you are you are living life
yes going through these lessons and
hopefully
this book can help people uh it can show
them to
to move forward well the de-scandalizing
i like that term because that's a type
of letting go
in a way because what happens you talk
about the younger people ryan but
as we get older we often cling to those
moments and say that defines me that's
who i
am well no the thing i talk about in the
book is your
your past self is merely an ancestor who
birthed you
but we don't have to cling to that and
so i like the idea of the
the d scandalizing we got some audience
questions here i thought we could dive
into those before we do
i threw up a twitter poll this morning
and it simply was two choices love
people
use things and at the moment by the way
if you're listening to this the day this
podcast comes out that this is the day
the book comes out
but you can go over to my twitter
account it's just twitter.com
jfm and you can vote on this right now
as of this recording it's 79
love people 21
use things there's no wrong answer here
yeah we do both but you get to pick on
that twitter poll
we have a question here from kim in
scranton pa
dude that's where the office is filming
no i'm like scranton is real
when i want to get rid of things that
are used
and can't be donated but i know that
they're going to sit
in a pile of trash for probably 100
years before they even
start to degrade what should i do
with these objects there's certain
things that
i know i can get rid of because i'm not
using them but to
throw them away hurts my heart
and i know that they are not
donatable because they're either half
used or so broken down
what we're really talking about here tk
is how do you let go of possessions i
pulled this from our website because
i need this reminder this is always a
reminder for me because i have the same
problem
i get caught up in the oh but i need to
find the perfect home for
the thing if i want to get rid of it now
the woman i encounter on the elevator
she's like i'm headed to goodwill i'm
getting rid of this stuff it's a burden
now why did she notice that because she
knew she was beginning to understand the
true cost
of our things and so real quick how to
let go of possessions
our possessions possess us we'll put a
link to this in the show notes
this is how we let go if a thing stops
adding value
sell it if it doesn't sell in a week
lower the price if it doesn't sell in 30
days
donate it if a donation place doesn't
accept it
recycle it and if it can't be recycled
trash it as a last resort once we let go
we're able to move on yeah and really
here kim
the the part that you're not connecting
the dots on yet but you're going to as
soon as you hear this it will click
before you very easily
once you let go you're able to move on
right now the real cost of holding on to
those things in your home or in your
office or in your car
in your closet or a storage locker
whatever it is
the cost is the inability
to move on that attachment so we never
think about the cost of our things
here's an excerpt from love people use
things it's page eight here
the price tag dangling from each new
widget
tells only a fraction of the story the
true cost of a thing extends well beyond
its price
there's the cost of storing the thing
maintaining the thing
cleaning the thing watering the thing
charging the thing accessorizing the
thing refueling the thing
changing the oil in the thing replacing
the batteries in the thing fixing the
thing repainting the thing taking care
of the thing
protecting the thing and of course when
it's all said and done
replacing the thing not to mention
the emotional and psychological calls of
our things
which are even more difficult to
quantify when you add it
all up the actual cost of owning a thing
is immeasurable so we better choose
carefully
what things we bring into our lives
because we can't afford
every thing yeah
yeah i love that remember when i kept
saying everything
and matt was like can you just say it
the correct way yes and i just don't
know how to say it
i don't know what else to say kim is
prolonging pain here
like she's putting it off the one thing
i'll say
is kim when as soon as you purchase that
thing you already hurt the environment
the holding on to it doesn't hurt the
environment less as soon as you
took that thing off the store shelf you
already hurt the environment
and all you're doing now is you're
prolonging the pain of letting that
thing go
uh i would encourage you to just donate
what you have you don't i mean
you don't you may not realize that some
of the things you think aren't donatable
might be
donatable now maybe she's got a half a
cheeseburger or something like yeah you
can't donate something like that
yeah but but let the donation place
decide on some of these things that
maybe you're on the fence with but
yeah ultimately you know what josh and i
wrote about the process of letting go
those are some very easy simple steps
and what this will do is help kim it'll
give herself permission
to put some of these things that yeah
they might end up in the landfill
the best way to really redeem yourself
here
is to stop purchasing crap that you
don't need
yeah it's the best thing you can do but
but sitting here and holding on to it
that's that's like a in a way like a
hoarder's mentality of like well you
know it might be able to be used one day
and uh yeah i can't donate it and oh i
don't want to put it in the landfill
like
we make up all these excuses but i can't
say it enough kim like as soon as you
purchase that thing and took it off the
shelf unfortunately
you already hurt the environment yeah
tk let's talk about some of these costs
the let's talk about the psychology
behind this
yeah so um from that perspective i would
say you know
the the first step to letting go of
stuff is letting go of the stories you
tell yourself about the stuff
right a story is kind of like the glue
that attaches us to these things that we
have a hard time letting go of it's like
if i got this letter from you know when
i was in sixth grade a girl that i liked
she wrote to me you know i'm trying to
pretend like people loved me when i was
in sixth grade but
you know it's the story about what this
means that makes it hard to let go
because that's just the piece of paper
you know with with the words written in
ink but it's the story like
you know if i let this go who who do i
become
can i still be me without this thing and
so even in this
even in this question about like you
know if i let go of things it's gonna be
kind of like waste if i can't donate it
and i throw it out that's gonna be
wasteful well that's a story that's a
story and it's a story that's rooted in
guilt
you know i need to let go of these
things because they're hindering my joy
they're getting in the way of my pursuit
of meaning but if i do that
i'm going to be a wasteful person and i
i think the solution to that is to say
it's better to trash your things
than to trash your life right it's
better to waste
that stuff that you don't need than to
waste away your
valuable years your valuable energy
holding on to things that are just
getting in the way of you becoming the
best possible version of yourself
dude that's good that's good i'm so good
i'm stealing that kim i wanted it on
twitter i want to send you a copy of our
minimalist rule book so we have a long
it's like maybe 30 pages you can
download it for free the minimalists.com
rule book because there's one rule in
there in particular i think you'll
really benefit from by the way there's
an attenuated version of these 16 rules
there's 16 rules for living with less
in love people use things you don't have
to buy the book in order to take
advantage of these rules so they're all
free right there on our website
the minimalists.com rule book but ryan
the there's a
rule that ryan came up with called the
spontaneous combustion rule oh yeah so
if you hold up an item you look at it
and say
okay if this spontaneously combusted
would i replace it or
would i feel relieved meaning like would
i buy this thing again
and clearly with these things that
you're talking about trashing
there's one other story that she might
be telling herself oh no one else wants
these things
that's not always true yeah and it may
be that you have you know of course
there's this old platitude
of well someone else's junk is someone
else's treasure right
yeah but that is often the case
platitudes are true they've just been
stripped of all of the emotion that make
them profound
but it doesn't take the truth out of
them and so
enjoy that minimalist rule book there's
also an audiobook version so kim if you
want that we'd be happy to send you that
as well the minimalists.com
slash rulebook we have a question here
from tessa
in toronto so i really enjoy photography
and cosmetology
they're both hobbies of mine and i'm
very passionate about both of them and
they bring me endless joy but they both
create
so much clutter um how do i justify
to my new minimalist attitude that
having more than one
dark red lipstick or highlighter or many
different props or backdrops is okay
if i know i'm gonna use them in the next
30 to 90 days
so you have some hobbies you have some
passions you have some creative outlets
that it seems are cluttering your life
i think it goes back to the stories that
we tell ourselves there right as a
minimalist i'm supposed to own nothing
and believe me i get it we're going to
do a future episode soon about
recluttering
in fact this is the first uh episode
we're recording in this new studio here
with the sound panels
and it sounds so much better now we're
tweaking some of the equipment and
everything
and with podcast sean and and jordan no
more we're and we got new lighting in
here and so
there are certain accoutrements that are
required
for us to film this podcast we've
decided we wanted to do a video version
of the podcast right now you see these
backdrops behind us these aren't really
backdrops
it's wrapping paper there's a gift
behind here it's a brand new studio
behind this wrapping paper we're going
to be unveiling it soon somewhere around
episode 300 i think we're 296
right now but in the meantime we're sort
of
hiding some additional clutter that's
that's behind us
now these are things that we're going to
use as
tessa said within a defined period of
time
and i think that's what's important
setting up those boundaries another one
of the the minimalist rules that we have
is the 90-90 rule
am i going to use this in the next 90
days have i used it in the last 90 days
if
not then i give myself permission
to let go what do you think tk what
about what about these boundaries and
also what about this
this sort of you know we did a whole
chapter and a lot of people use things
about creativity
ryan and i were doing an interview
yesterday with uh l magazine the dutch
version of l magazine
and the woman was at first was like when
i was i read the book and
it was like there was this one
relationship the relationship with
creativity
that it almost felt like it didn't fit
at first with all these other
relationships why why is why did you
decide to write about it and i said
because we've been lied to we've been
told we're consumers and that's
partially true consumption isn't a
problem
consumerism though is a problem the
we are all creators yeah but we've
been lied to for so long we've consumed
so much to try to become happy
that we've lost our way we've we forgot
that we're creators and what tessa is
saying is
i feel like minimalism doesn't align
with my creativity
and what i would say to tessa is no
minimalism
is about creativity it's stripping away
the excess so we have
the space we have the blank canvas from
which to create
yeah that's exactly right like we have
to make a distinction between minimalism
and dogmatism right like minimalism is
a lifestyle where you contextualize your
material possessions with a sense of
purpose
you say there's nothing wrong with
matter that you know there's nothing
wrong with physical substance
but there is something wrong with
consuming a bunch of things thinking
that it's going to make us happy
and then crowding our our space with
things that distract us from
what makes life truly meaningful yes and
you know to your point about
you know creativity and consumption as
human beings we're not just here to
consume and you know a lot of
advertising kind of convinces us that we
can but
we actually become depressed pretty
quickly when we're divorced from the
creative process
and so anytime you feel like okay i got
a bunch of stuff
but my life is feeling empty even though
my shelves are full
don't just ask yourself how can i get
rid of my stuff but ask yourself
how can i feel the space surrounding my
stuff with more creative energy
how can i maybe get a new
a new use out of the things that i
already have how can i be more creative
with
with how i employ them and so on so i i
think that's a
i think the creativity piece is
absolutely essential but you know to
answer this question i would say
let go of the story of guilt that says
there's a certain number of things which
if you have
makes you some kind of sinner and puts
you in minimalism purgatory
this this is not a religion um there is
no objective
right or wrong number of things for you
to have if you are an artist
and you need many different colors you
know who's to say well
12 is more than enough well not if you
need 13 colors in order to be able to
paint your picture you know
um so let go of that story of guilt and
make sure that you are analyzing the
things in your life by how much use you
make of them
and if you're using them give yourself
that permission and if you're not then
as josh said give them away recycle them
do what you got to do
yeah yeah makes me think that uh tessa
here should ask herself the question
are my things getting in the way of my
creativity oh and if the answer is yes
then yeah tessa you got too much stuff
but what i want tessa to ask herself is
are you worried about
how you are judging yourself or are you
worried about how
like josh tk and i are going to judge
your stuff yeah
because sometimes we get this guilt
based on other people's judgments and
what really matters tessa is what you
think about you so you know ask
yourselves those two questions
is this stuff getting in the way of my
creativity and am i judging myself or am
i looking at myself through other
people's eyes
you bring up a great point about asking
questions ryan so in the creativity
chapter it starts with
this whole story it's probably the the
most um
endearing story of mine in the book it's
when i got my first real job
at 13 but then uh so i'll just read the
i'll read it because i got my
actual first job way a decade before
that so i'll read this because it's
really about questions here
this is relationship 6 creativity i got
my first real job at 13
the summer between junior high and high
school spinning cotton candy at
americana
a discount amusement park on the
outskirts of middletown ohio
but my first ever job was a decade
earlier
in the mid 80s we had just moved to
american village
a bland apartment complex composed of
dozens of brown brick buildings
separated by thin
landing strips of brown grass 20 miles
south of dayton
our one bedroom unit was entirely beige
the carpets and walls and appliances
all shades of monotony a couple weeks
before my fourth birthday
i asked i asked to buy a gi joe action
figure
at the local hills department store mom
explained we didn't have enough money to
both pay our bills and purchase the
plastic man i wanted
so we'd have to wait till friday for the
toy soldier
being that i was only four and i didn't
understand money or commerce or delayed
gratification
i figured i could help that afternoon i
marched down to our apartment's main
office and told them
i needed a job after she realized it
wasn't a joke the woman behind the
counter smiled and then whispered
something to her co-worker before
returning her benevolent eyes to me
okay if you pick up litter around our
building we'll give you a dollar a week
she said
two i said
excuse me i'll do it for two dollars a
week
neither woman could contain her laughter
was this little boy negotiating his
salary
two dollars huh she said one for my mom
to pay the bills
the other so i can buy toys flesh your
heart
she said and then shook my hand to seal
the deal
every weekend that summer i dropped off
a small trash bag
filled with dozens of glass bottles and
food wrappers and scraps of paper
and every weekend i returned home with a
dollar for my mom
and a dollar for me let's ignore that i
was grossly underpaid and that we were
probably breaking several
child labor laws and let's focus instead
on the wisdom i absorbed that summer
while i didn't learn about budgeting or
inflation or sound financial principles
i picked up many valuable lessons that
formed a foundation
for my aspirations i learned about the
payoff from drudgery
i learned it's impossible to have the
peaks without the valleys
i learned about earning an income by
creating value
and i learned about not sitting around
and relying on others
most important i learned the power
of asking you see had i not been willing
to ask for that first quote
job then not only would i have missed
out on my first taste of earning income
but i would have missed out on the
knowledge gained through the experience
itself
it turns out that any creative endeavor
be it writing a book opening a yoga
studio or baking a cake
or photography or cosmology or whatever
else
your whatever your creative endeavor
whatever it is
is ultimately just a series of questions
all creativity is birthed from
continuous
questioning and our creations merely
answer those questions
who would benefit from this what makes
my solution
interesting or unique where is the
greatest
need for my perspective why hasn't this
problem
already been solved how can i better
serve others with my creativity
and what's the thing i can't not
do now tessa
you're asking yourself some questions
here but maybe there's some other
questions to be asking
because if you ask those questions you
might realize that
there are certain things i need to solve
problems to
i understand what you're trying to
create and then
the tools just become tools if they're
useful to you great
if not you give yourself permission to
let go
also i'm going to send you a copy of the
book a lot of people use things you want
the audiobook
if you like our podcast you'll really
like the audio book because ryan and i
read the entire thing or if you want the
hardcover or the ebook we're happy to
send those to you
as well ryan what time is it you know
what time it is
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer your text messages you can
text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654
wait wait i'm gonna be so rude because i
gotta say something about this story you
just read
tell me it's so dope it's so dope by the
way uh you got your next book title
a dollar for mom and a dollar for me
that's good
subtitled the essence of true abundance
i love this because one of the things
that story illustrates is that
the desire for more is a form of
pathology when it's born out of a need
to compensate for a lack of self-respect
a lack of self-love a lack of
self-directed purpose
the desire for more is the definition of
true abundance when it's born out of a
desire to be
truly generous and to serve others so
what i love about your story is
you were actually seeking more money not
less
but why is that abundance not because
you were seeking more money but you were
seeking the money
for the purpose of serving another human
being it's not about
less or more it's about the purpose that
you're using things for and i didn't
even intend to rhyme we got it
nice nice i dig that man so much so
so i i like what you're saying here
because you the the
creativity the questioning all of that
but also the the abundance mindset
yeah i heard someone once say that you
don't ever want to look in
at what your neighbor has unless they
don't have enough
yeah that's the only time you want to
look you compare yourself to them
because
if they don't have enough and i do if i
have more than enough
and that's the same thing with with my
mom here is like i knew we didn't have
enough right and now i didn't understand
math so i thought a dollar was going to
solve our problems right
and i would bring it home she could buy
milk with it i thought etc
but it was it wasn't about now it's like
oh i look at my neighbor and it's like
oh they have more than me
i should get either get some of their
stuff is now mine
or i need to do something to become more
like that person
you know anthony o'neil and i had this
awesome discussion
about just money and how there are all
these stereotypes around wealth
where like the desire for wealth is
often demonized and sometimes we have a
tendency to
over spiritualize the experience of lack
and
and one of the the overlooked things
about abundance is that
sometimes when you don't desire more
that can be a form of unhealthy
selfishness because it can be an
indicator that you only think about
yourself
you only think about your own needs
you're not aware of anybody else who
who needs help and sometimes the desire
for more the desire to make more of
yourself
to maximize your capacity to create
wealth is born out of seeing other
people struggle and say
it's not enough for me to just provide
for me and my family i want to make a
difference in the lives of other people
so i'm gonna push myself to achieve a
new level
in my own life by actualizing my
potential so that i can be a greater
asset to other people it's not just
about things it's not just about stuff
that's what makes generosity generosity
not that you have more numbers behind
your name
not that your net worth is higher but
that your desire to serve
is bringing out the best in you oh
that's beautiful
it's reminding me of what the publisher
wrote for the description of the book
the very last paragraph is one sentence
because once you have less
you can make room for the right kind of
more that's it
now amen i wouldn't say right wrong
morally let's be clear about that
what what the publisher is is
highlighting there is like
well you know we're searching for one
kind of more and it's making us
miserable
we never even think about this other
more yeah and it requires a
a a subtraction an uncovering of sorts
in order to find that abundance maybe
the abundance abundance has always been
there
yeah and we've simply covered it up with
all this stuff
yeah now this lightning round tk you'll
recall
since this is your ninth time on the
podcast is it nine times
yes this is incredible yeah he's nine
times in the finals i i sent him a
picture of uh
of bill russell this morning because
bill russell has this picture with
wearing all 11 of his rings and i'm like
you're getting close
and then he sent me a picture back of
robert orry who happens to have seven
rings but
i'll finally pass it up yeah anyway
during the lightning round that's where
we do our best to answer questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these
minimal maxims in the show notes so
people can share our
pithy answers on social media if they
like and now you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place
thanks to our good friend jessica lynn
williams over at minimal maxims dot com
now ryan who has a question for us a
question from mindy here
she wants to know how do i rejuvenate my
creativity
when i'm overwhelmed by burnout well
here i'm going to pick the answer from
you but it's not my pithy answer it's tk
coleman's
so just this week he tweeted this and i
was like oh my gosh
this is perfect for this question so
mindy again says how do i rejuvenate my
creativity when i'm overwhelmed by
burnout
and here's the tweet that i got from tk
coleman we do not create because we
know that our desire or that our ideas
will live on we do not create
because we know that our ideas will live
on we create because
creativity is part and parcel of what it
means
to be fully alive yeah yeah
that's why that's the problem with
consumption or consumerism rather
the the problem with consumerism as an
ideology buying things is going to make
me
happy it's going to make me fully
alive but it does the opposite
it often not not that there's anything
wrong with the material things as we
said
right but the the consumption of those
things doesn't fill the void like we
thought it would
by the way the void was just created by
marketers and advertisers and
and major corporations anyway yeah yes
but in comparison to make us feel
inadequate
and what you're saying in this tweet
from what at least what i what i tweezed
out of it is
man tk if we want to fill the void it's
filling with creativity not consumption
yeah yeah i love that man my favorite
chuck norris quote is
slow down to go faster i just heard
someone say the other day that
if you can't find an hour to meditate
then you need to meditate for two hours
a day
yeah right there is there is a quality
of meaning and success that wisdom
will bring that work can never deliver
and so
if you find yourself in these
overwhelmed spaces and you're trying to
figure out how to get more creative you
got to remember
you can't let your light shine if you're
too busy putting out fires all the time
so you have to make that distinction
between reacting and creating and if
you're spending most of your life in a
reactionary space
that's that's a space that's not going
to reciprocate energy so
i'm way beyond 140 characters but what i
would say
is slow down create space for the wisdom
that is within
and let your creativity come from that
non-reactionary space
there was another pithy answer you gave
and it was you cannot let your light
shine if you're too
if you're too busy putting out other
fires edit everything out and just just
tweet that podcast on like he spells it
s-e-a-n
no he doesn't he spells it the correct
way right exactly but and if you spell
it any other way you're wrong
not just incorrect you're morally wrong
you're a bad person
now we love all seans no matter how you
spell yes even if you
are wrong even if you're a scene
i'm going to pick the answer for you
ryan creativity is essential consumerism
is not that's self-explanatory you got
something for us
i do and i just want to i just want to
preface it with this mindy uh i come
from a place of
of relating not of judgment with this
comment i've been there
so here's my pithy answer show me your
calendar and i'll show you your
priorities
and this is something that josh and i
have said many times before
uh it's very apt here mindy um the fact
is is that
what i'm hearing you say is like i'm not
inspired i'm not inspired to be creative
anymore because i'm burnt out
well if you're gonna wait around for
inspiration it'll probably never come
but if you plan for inspiration you plan
to be creative
that's when it will start to come it's
it's planning for creation first
first and then the inspiration will come
so show me your calendar i'll show you
your priorities mindy
you asked me if i struggle this this is
an area that i've struggled with
um even recently i
i felt like life hit me from
multiple different angles and came
really close to burying me in a lot of
ways
there's a story i'm going to try to
tweeze out of him on the maximal episode
i know we can't tell it publicly he may
not even tell it privately
but we'll we'll see we'll see they'll go
ahead and dance around the edges right
now
i don't even know the story man it's
killing me all right in the spirit of
being transparent i just want to say i
struggle with some things
no but i i seriously do know what it
what it means to
to burn out and there's a paradoxical
thing that happens with creativity if if
you're a dreamer
and you come up with creative ideas
that's a really fun stage but once those
ideas begin to work
they create a lot of tasks for you and
it's very easy to kind of slip into
maintenance mode where you're managing
all of the responsibilities that come
along with creating results
and so i have been in many stages in
life where
i was inspired i'm generating a lot of
ideas then those ideas start working and
maybe i have customers or promises to
keep
and now i'm entirely in maintenance mode
my energy's being drained i'm losing
creativity
my output is really high i'm very
productive and respectable to society
but i'm losing myself in the process and
i even had to recently just just step
away i stepped away from social media
for a couple of weeks
my wife and i went back home to chicago
and michigan and just kind of stepped
away from the fray
because i had to realize like man if you
lose yourself
it doesn't matter what it is you're
giving to someone else
like you know the the the real treasure
is not
the golden egg it's it's the goose that
lays them you gotta protect
the goose that lays the golden egg if
you know what i'm saying yes yeah
and that's why we did the the self
chapter in the book as well we'll dive
more into that on
the maximum episode now we have the most
odd added value segment this week that
we've ever had thanks
to our good friend tk coleman and and
we're going to get to that added value
segment in a moment but first here's
some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners check them out
hi this is kira calling from chicago i
just listened to episode 12 on money and
wanted to share
some advice that helped me in my
minimalist lifestyle during and after
college
my dad advised that i didn't attend a
university where the tuition
would cost more than what i would make
in my first year entry salary with that
degree
after following that advice i picked up
a second job after graduation to pay off
my loans and i continue to live with
roommates to keep costs low
between both of those approaches i paid
off over
twenty thousand dollars in debt in less
than a year the financial freedom has
opened up more doors than i could ever
imagine
so i was able to quit my second job
afford
to buy a new car travel the country and
move
to my dream city to pursue my life's
passion all within five years
time it was a long and difficult road
working 70 plus hours a week for a year
but it was all short-term pain for
long-term gain and worth every initial
sacrifice to get me to where i am today
hey there my name is sam mcgee i'm from
spokane washington and i wanted to
respond
to the episode on creativity with matt
diavela
i love the ideas that are expressed in
this episode which i do feel are
consistently hit upon
in every short documentary that matt
puts out every week
i have been a long time follower as a
documentary filmmaker myself
i've spent the last year replacing the
urge to consume
with the habit of creating this is
one of the topics you discussed in this
episode
i've found in my commercial work and in
my personal life it's
become a lifestyle of creating
photographing my family
creating films about my kids for the
purpose
of sharing that art with my family for
the purpose of
group therapy with my wife as we learn
to be the best
parents possible for my kids that's a
that's the point that i want to make
filmmaking
creating for me is
a form of therapy it's a powerful way
for me
to process the world and invite others
to join me in that conversation
invite others to engage and consider
these moments in their own lives
i'm thankful for that invitation that
you put out there on the internet every
day
with the minimalist quote content as
well as matt's
content i do personally need the
consistency i choose
to listen for the 10th time
because i need to be reminded to kill
the habit
of constantly consuming all right y'all
big thanks to tk
coleman for joining us today we have a
bunch more surprise questions for tk
this week over on patreon in the
meantime you can check them out
revolutionary one is his show you can
follow him on twitter and instagram
we'll put links to both of those in the
show notes
and then check them out on the maximum
episode this week that's on the
minimalist
private podcast that's patreon.com the
minimalist but first
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist you know the new
book came out today love people use
things because the opposite
never works hard cover e-book audio book
but
we release this at a time where we can't
really do a full tour yet
however next week we are
going to announce the official love
people
use things tour we're coming to 20
cities us
and canada if you're on our email list
you'll be the
second to know the first to know will be
our patreon supporters they get
tickets uh 24 hours in advance so they
get the best seats in the house and who
knows
tk we might even convince tk coleman to
come to some of these tour stops with us
and join us on stage
i'm gonna drive to all of them and crash
them
we want tk there and so it's gonna be
all over the place the south the east
the west this fall this winter the
minimalists.com
slash tour to find the city closest to
you
now i know that a lot of you will want
to get tickets now some of these are
going to be some smaller venues i have
to tell you this in advance because
tickets for our last tour we did 50
cities and i think 43
45 of them sold out right yeah and
they'll sell out and people always ask
when are you gonna come to dallas
when are you coming to boston when are
you coming to seattle well
now the answer is fall and winter and
now is your chance don't wait for the
tickets to sell out if you want to
attend
we've priced them very very reasonably
to cover our travel costs
we're not making a bunch of money from
these tours the tickets are inexpensive
and so now is an opportunity now if they
sell out and scalpers start selling them
on stub hub or whatever
i can't do anything about that so now is
your chance
to be the first in line to get tickets
for that also this
uh this week uh yesterday and today ryan
and i are going around to bookstores
in la county and signing copies of love
people
use things throughout l.a county local
indie book shops
as well as a few barnes and noble as
well so if you do pick up a copy in la
county there may even be
an autographed copy for you and no
matter where you are if you pick up a
copy of love people use things
our local meetup groups free local
meetup groups over at minimalist.org tk
we have 100 free local meetup groups in
eight different countries
the there's also one that's called an
online city so for folks who don't have
a
a meetup group close to them there's
this online city
16 000 people in there who all encourage
each other with their stuff their
relationships their careers
etc and that minimalist.org
group is going to do a special love
people use things
it's a group challenge they're all going
to do this group challenge together the
publishers set this up they've been
working with jess
on this who runs our social media and so
we've got this whole challenge for the
month of
august if you are over there
minimalist.org it's free to join
we don't want any money from you for
that if you can you can also meet
open-minded like-minded people who are
exploring
just like you are and if you enjoy the
book this is the only time i'm going to
ask this i'm going to ask it one time
one time only if you enjoy love people
use things
please leave us a review on amazon
barnes and noble
and goodreads if you enjoy the book it's
one of the best ways to help us spread
this message of living intentionally
with less now for added value this week
tk coleman so you know
it's july and it's kind of today feels
like christmas
in july i thought we would end this
episode
because tk is here tk listens to
christmas music every day of his life
i'm told and so with our book coming out
feels like christmas to me
let's end this week's episode
with love is christmas by sarah
bareilles
this is a recommendation from tk coleman
by the way
we're going to end the episode there by
the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like
is the desire to win a mental illness
uh oh we might disagree about this tk
why
is the risk of criticism or rejection so
unbearable to me is it loving to
separate yourself from
people you're very close to if your
values are not aligned
which relationships do you struggle with
the most
and what do ryan joshua and tk
disagree about plus a million more
questions for tk
and the minimalists and if you want to
hear all that join us on the minimalist
private podcast this week visit
patreon.com the minimalist to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
private podcast plays in your favorite
podcast
app we've simplified the pricing there's
also annual prices you can save a bunch
of money on that as well
it's relatively inexpensive but you get
all the archives you also
get access to our private community over
5000 people over there on patreon who
interact with each other
so that's patreon.com the minimalist you
can follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and
instagram at the minimalists come to one
of our live podcast shows
minimalists.com
tours the website for that if you have a
question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist
and if you want our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple sunday emails for free
whenever we send those out and if you
leave here today with just
one message let it be this
love people and use things because the
opposite
never works thanks for listening yo
we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it